[Musique]
les jours de rêve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
restez bien sur la voie de circulation
restez bien midi il n'y ait pas de trous
dans le cocktail
alors on va voir les images fortes
d'abord c'est une des images très très
fortes de la journée je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu ici autour de la table dans
l'après-midi on marche des
manifestations parisiennes un groupe de
Black Box c'en est pris une voiture
c'est de la voiture d'un médecin de SOS
Médecins regardez ces images je pense
que justement jusque là les Black Blocs
les personnes que l'on voit à l'écran
c'était relativement tenu tranquille
peut-être parce que se rendait compte
elle-même que leur action était nuisible
au mouvement ou que c'était pas le
moment qu'ils étaient très impopulaire
je pense que il y a voilà c'est une
petite minorité ça existe depuis
longtemps ça dépend aussi de la
stratégie policière il est clair que
depuis le départ du préfet de police le
changement de préfet de police on a une
stratégie policière qui était plus
souple qui était plus efficace
alors le médecin a ensuite pu partir
regarder des images de Clément Lanaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
incroyable ces images incroyables
vraiment alors il y a eu d'autres
tensions entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors maintenant on a des choses alors
on voulait montrer déjà les images voilà
ces images qui sont voilà poignantes et
c'est vrai qu'après on voulait montrer
aussi des moments aussi voilà qu'on a
qu'on a remarqué sur BFM à chaque
journée de manifestation ils interrogent
des mecs dans les transports et à chaque
fois il y a une note regardez avec un
peu d'organisation vous voyez ça se
passe pas trop mal et Anne va partir
attention
voilà ce qui peut se passer quand
justement on court on essaie d'attraper
le seul train qui part voilà ça c'est en
revanche le type de difficulté qui peut
qui peut survenir aujourd'hui
on se souvient la dernière fois ils
avaient eu aussi des galères ils avaient
fait louper le train à quelqu'un voulait
revoir cette image et là je vais prendre
le train direction Versailles et je le
mets
a été maintenue à 5h33 je vous êtes dans
quel état d'esprit ce matin ouh là là le
train j'ai perdu le train je suis navré
[Applaudissements]
et on sait les jours de mobilisation le
plus dur c'est souvent de se déplacer
sur les quais des métros les usagers et
des usagers applaudissent tous les
métros tellement ils n'en pouvaient plus
d'attendre en regardant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
calme-toi s'il te plaît
en arrivant à la gare de Lyon à Paris
ils ont mis le feu à de nombreux pneus
mais même eux ils ont vu de vie qu'ils
allaient ils ont vu de vie en fait
qu'ils allaient un peu trop loin que
c'était pas le délire quoi
[Musique]
on va ranger la prochaine fois tu mets
moins de bonheur
c'est magique c'est magique sérieux
c'est magique alors on se souvient lors
des dernières manifestations des
collectifs à créer des petites Corées
pour lutter contre la réforme des
retraites et on a eu droit aujourd'hui à
une nouvelle chorégraphie j'aime bien
j'aime toujours moi regarde
[Musique]
allez allez allez allez allez
toujours sympathique et évidemment les
manifestants sont très mobilisés et
motivés aujourd'hui il y en a un qui
était plus focus sur le foot que sur les
retraites
pour Amiens également beaucoup d'argent
et donc
pour nous voilà c'est un sentiment
d'échec de toute façon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
également beaucoup d'argent et donc
pour nous voilà c'est un sentiment
d'échec de toute façon
[Applaudissements]
je serais très prochainement à Amiens
j'ai ma vie voilà je vais aller Amiens
les Chéries la majorité des cortèges se
sont passés sans débordement et dans la
bonne humeur à tel point que certains
avaient même choisi de venir déguiser
regardez voilà si il y en a qui font ça
dans la bonne humeur c'est sympathique
aussi parce que le message passe aussi
regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
il est 20h41 si vous nous rejoignez bien
sûr on fait le point sur tout ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui on aura deux
témoignages très forts dans un instant
et puis on reviendrait aussi sur Pierre
Palmade mais pour le moment plus
insolite on a trouvé une manifestante
très en colère alors elle est très
énervée je vous cache pas mais on avait
du mal à se concentrer sur son
énervement parce qu'elle avait un objet
assez insolite avec elle
moi je pense qu'il faut toujours appeler
un chat voilà donc c'est une table c'est
une teub c'est un champ
une nouvelle manifestation c'est donc
lancer aujourd'hui et donc été
aujourd'hui c'était à Paris c'était
depuis le boulevard Raspail et nous y
étions avec nos équipes et heureusement
car il s'est passé des trucs de fou que
personne n'a vu déjà il y avait plein de
personnes déguisées dans la manif comme
je vous l'ai dit mais le problème c'est
que les costumes en fait ils étaient pas
tous réussissent un peu comme les
apnings de TPMP
il y en a qu'on confondu la grève avec
mardi gras on a retrouvé presque Astérix
alors qu'est-ce que c'est que ce beau
déguisement pour cette magnifique
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire on peut vous
demander pas de retraite je Ken onyx
donc 64 c'est non on a aussi retrouvé
Vercingétorix version Aix-en-Provence
de ce gouvernement on a trouvé un
candidat de Koh-Lanta visiblement sa
barque à dérivé jusqu'à Montparnasse
c'est quoi le slogan c'est archi archi
en colère quoi parce que vous êtes
architecte on a retrouvé un super héros
qui a fusionné avec Benjamin Castaldi on
comprenait pas tout ce qu'ils disent
Batman
comment qu'est-ce que vous faites là bah
moi j'ai pas envie de quoi apprendre les
choses qu'elles sont 4 ans 18 ans et
Monsieur vous rigolez si vous vous
demandiez où était Charlie on l'a
retrouvé comment allez-vous ça va bien
alors pourquoi cette manifestation et
pourquoi pas on a aussi vu la fille
spirituelle de Brigitte Bardot
pas mal un message pour le gouvernement
on n'est pas des animaux les animaux
leur demande pas leur consentement les
fait travailler on utilise leur peau
leur cuire leur carcasses leur viande et
du coup nous en fait on meugle pas et
enfin on a croisé le chemin d'une boule
à facettes on est là pour la joie on est
là pour la machine donc j'ai vraiment eu
ma tenue la plus belle mais une fois
ça représente ma tenue de soirée
avec la casquette c'est GT s'il vous
plaît
j'adore j'adore avec la casquette CGT
c'est extraordinaire moi j'adore ça on a
aussi croisé Thierry Daniel c'est un
couple c'est pas bon c'est un couple
c'est un couple lunaire qui avait une
solution assez darka pour
lutter contre la réforme des retraites
regarde ça fait partie de la cellule des
macronisation de la réforme des
retraites alors comment on fait
c'est partout
et alors 24 heures vous êtes à l'abri
il y avait aussi beaucoup de chanteurs
dans la manifestation bon pas sur qui
viennent chanter tout de suite voilà
dans les [__] ou un single un jour
dans TPMP mais il y avait des bons
délires regardez
on continue notre périple puis on savait
plus trop si on était au sein de la
manifestation ou sur le plateau de The
Voice
t'inquiète pas on est là on lâche rien
il y a les gilets jaunes des ennemis
numéro 1 Elisabeth si tu savais
ce que ça me fait d'offrir une petite
culotte pour les filles le 8 mars alors
ça fait quoi ça fait plaisir
[Musique]
on a croisé aussi notre
idole cette manifestation il est
magnifique qui s'appelle Edouard doit
Eduardo c'est un ancien chanteur des
années 80 il avait fait une chanson qui
s'appelle je t'aime le lundi exactement
en exclure ces deux nouveaux singles je
vous dis ça c'est une exclu et c'est non
mais vraiment là ça c'est juste c'est
juste magique regardez je suis un noir
d'homme le lundi ah et j'ai fait deux
chansons j'ai fait une chanson intime
Macron qui s'appelle teciottes et j'ai
fait une chanson qui s'appelle chanson
pour Madame borne on peut avoir un
extrait de Macron
Macron où tu as mis mon pouvoir d'argent
tu l'as mis tout au fond tout au fond de
tes chiottes tu l'as mis tout au fond
tout au fond de tes chiottes tu ne les
brises menus les burnes bornes tu ne les
brise menu les burnes bornes laisse mon
peuple éjaculaire se guise laisse le
peuple éjacule à sa guise
il y a une idée c'est pas Jean-Jacques
Goldman mais il y a une idée il y a un
truc au niveau de la rime voilà
on a aussi croisé des personnages ou en
couleur dans le cortège entre le mec
totalement indécis et celui qui je
prends pour un philosophe il y a
toujours des des philosophes comme ça
cortège regardez on a rencontré des
personnages incroyables au sein de cette
manifestation des adeptes de jeux de
mots Macron nous casse les murs quand on
lui s'aborne pas mal on est également
tombé sur des retraités de
Seine-et-Marne très en colère allez là
c'est les retraitée de Selena ah très
bien et alors les convictions de
retraités de Seine-et-Marne c'est quoi
aujourd'hui
on a aussi découvert un grévistes plutôt
indécis elle est bien la réforme
pourquoi vous manifestez alors parce que
je manifeste je manifeste contre la
réforme en fait d'accord événement
Socrate a tenu à réagir pour TPMP
l'ouverture d'esprit n'est pas une
fracture du crâne mon cher c'est beau
oui oui pas mal ça rime pas mais c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal en plus en dit
long sur ce c'est potentialités du genre
humain et aujourd'hui c'est nécessaire
d'entendre tout le monde
et cette diversité qui existe dans notre
pays je crois qu'on devrait l'utiliser
pour élever le niveau
on a aussi fait la rencontre de la sœur
de Francis Lalanne on est le 7 demain le
8 la journée des droits international de
la femme le 9 Mars Attaque voilà
7 8 9 Mars Attaque pour ceux qui l'ont
pas oui comme une piste mais bon voilà
et enfin on est tombé sur un manifestant
overcook un message pour le gouvernement
un peu mais ça je parle le gouvernement
s'il vous plaît quand tout le monde est
pas d'accord faites un effort quoi c'est
vrai que c'est un effort
laissez tomber sur un mec qui juste venu
histoire de kiffer dans la vallée
franchement voilà on n'a jamais vu ça
dans une maïs le gars était juste venu
qui fait un petit peu voir des gens quoi
en 2027 je pense que
mais
faudrait pas le créer ici quoi
tu en penses quoi aussi
[Rires]